qué posibilidades hay de que se anule el
derecho legal al aborto y cuáles serían
sus consecuencias
desafortunadamente las probabilidades
son altas sería muy ingenuo de parte
nuestra como litigantes del caso que
está en cuestión es momento de la corte
suprema e ignorar el hecho de que es muy
probable que se tenga una mayoría de
votos a favor del proyecto de ley que se
filtró las consecuencias serían que se
anularía el reconocimiento del derecho
constitucional en la interrupción del
embarazo y se abriría la puerta de más
de 28 estados en este momento se
activarán leyes que criminalizarían este
derecho de salud está este servicio de
salud ahora qué pasaría si cada estado
pudiera regular el aborto si la
jurisprudencia de roe versus wade porque
la penalización del aborto pondría en
riesgo el derecho a la intimidad
el riesgo del derecho a la intimidad
porque ya no va a ser una decisión
absolutamente personal que cada perfecta
en sus circunstancias económicas de
salud sociales va a tomar sino que
simplemente no va a tener ninguna opción
va a tener que continuar con el embarazo
en aquellos estados en que el mismo esté
prohibido y cuando busque porque eso es
lo que va a pasar las mujeres van
desesperadas y así ha sido
históricamente a buscar maneras
inseguras de interrumpir el embarazo
van a exponerse a una penalización
entonces esto solamente va a agravar una
situación
social y salud pública en este país
como lo mencionábamos anteriormente el
presidente joe biden dijo que su
gobierno está listo para garantizar el
derecho legal al aborto también lo
dijeron congresistas liberales sería
posible revertir un fallo del supremo
nosotros nuestra organización lleva años
impulsando un proyecto de ley para que
él se
constitucionalizó y se proteja de manera
federal los derechos reproductivos en
este país es un proyecto de ley bastante
comprensivo que más va más allá del
simple hecho de la decisión privada de
abortar o no y nosotros esperamos que el
congreso y el presidente de la republica
actúen en consecuencia con el grado de
peligro que representaría perder este
derecho y aprueben en consecuencia este
proyecto